LAWMAKERS, DO THEY REALLY THINK
THAT POLICE SHOULD BE DISMANTLED
AND DEFUNDED?
HERE WITH A FULL REPORT,
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, OUR FRIEND
FROM A CORRESPONDENT ON THE
GROUND LAWRENCE JONES.
I CALL HIM ELLIJAY.
I MISSED HAVING YOU ON THE SHOW
WHEN YOU WERE AWAY FOR A LITTLE
BIT AND NOW YOU’RE BACK OUT,
GLAD TO HAVE YOU BACK ON THE
ROAD.
>> THANK YOU, GOOD EVENING.
THE DEFUND POLICE MOVEMENT MIGHT
BE THE LATEST SOCIAL MEDIA
HASHTAG BUT A NEW YAHOO! NEWS
BOWLPOLL FINDS THAT ONLY 65% OF
AMERICANS OPPOSED IT.
I TALKED WITH NEW YORKERS TODAY
AND THIS IS WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY
SAY.
>> WENT ALL THE ISSUES THAT’S
GOING ON, SOME PEOPLE SAY WE
SHOULD DEFUND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
SHOULD WE GET RID OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> I DON’T THINK WE SHOULD GET
RID OF IT, BUT GET OUT THE ONES
WHO ARE NOT PERFECT OR BAD.
>> A COUPLE OF BAD COPS DID
SOMETHING BAD OR DESTRUCTIVE,
WHY SHOULD WE GET RID OF THE
WHOLE POLICE DEPARTMENT?
>> SO WE SHOULD KEEP THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT OR DEFUND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
WHY SHOULD WE KEEP THE POLICE
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE HERE TO
PROTECT US.
>> I THINK MORE FUNDING SHOULD
BE ALLOCATED TO PREPARING AND
PREPPING THE OFFICERS THAT ARE
IN TRAINING TO DEAL WITH THE
SOCIAL ISSUES AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY WORK IN.
>> SHOULD BE DEFUND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT?
>> YES AND NO.
KIND OF FEEL LIKE YOU SHOULDN’T
AND FEEL LIKE YOU SHOULD.
>> SHOULD JUST IMPROVE THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> DO AWAY WITH WHAT IS IT
CALLED, THE CHOKE HOLD?
I AGREE WITH YOU, YES.
>> WITH ALL THE ATTENTION THAT’S
BEEN GOING ON RIGHT NOW IN THE
CITY, WE NEED TO TRY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO DIFFUSE IT AND ALSO
SHOW THE PEOPLE THAT OKAY, THE
POLICE ARE HERE, WE ARE NOT YOUR
ENEMY, WE ARE HERE TO HELP YOU
AND TO SERVE YOU.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE, MOST PEOPLE
THAT I SPOKE TO DIDN’T WANT TO
DEFUND THE POLICE, BUT THEY DO
THINK CERTAIN REFORMS NEED TO
TAKE PLACE.
BACK TO YOU.
>> Sean: SO WE HAVE BEEN
TOGETHER AND YOU HAVE MET MY
MARTIAL ARTS INSTRUCTOR, LET’S
SAY.
YOU KNOW WHO I’M TALKING ABOUT.
IF WE HAD MORE TRAINING FOR
EXAMPLE, IF YOU TAKE YOUR HAND
AND WAIT THE PALM OF YOUR HAND
AT YOUR FIST AND REMEMBER, HE
WAS IN HANDCUFFS.
YOU JUST PUT A LITTLE PRESSURE
ON THAT OUT, SIMPLE THINGS, THEY
DON’T KNOW THIS.
WE CAN TRAIN THEM FOR THESE
THINGS.
>> YOU SHOULD HOST THESE
CONFERENCES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.